[Rires]
il ya longtemps que la famille weylandt
n'avais pas ri aux éclats comme les oies
l'inde a vécu un véritable cauchemar au
ch et celle des privées derana dorval où
elle a perdu son mari kenneth weylandt a
succombé à la coved 19
tout comme de nombreux autres résidents
koné weylandt
privé de ses proches a été hospitalisé
malade de lakovic 19 déshydraté soulier
faute de personnel pour les cinq enfants
il était inconcevable que leur mère
retourne dans cet établissement parce
que tu es certain si l'euro continue de
perdre contact avec sa famille signalé
sa mort ils ont loué un appartement
meublé
peter et sa soeur la soignent 24 heures
par jour 7 jours sur 7 avec l'aide du
clsc une solution radicale en temps de
crise sanitaire dont pierre puis moi le
premier de ce qui est arrivé du ch au
sol dès le premier ministre legault
s'est engagé à revoir le fonctionnement
de tout le réseau
en attendant d'autres familles songe à
ramener leurs proches à la maison mais
bon c'est valides comme réflexion mais
il ya des enjeux importants des enjeux
pour la sécurité du patient pour la
sécurité de ses proches
et donc je pensais c'est des choses
qu'il faut vraiment réfléchir parce que
devenir projets dans n'est pas tâche
facile des jo de complot mais accusée à
14 après midi parce que parfois mam
appelés vers 3 heures du matin sur le
problème parmi les mesures qui pour le
gériatre québec doit revoir en
profondeur les soins prodigués à ces
bâtisseurs si on peut réévaluer les
soins donnés en communauté les soins à
domicile
je pense que ça va être aussi essentiel
pour éviter d hébergement éventuellement
la famille weylandt pour sa part ne
regrette pas son choix mais plus
inquiète de la vie de ma mère
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
ces achats on sait que ce qui se passe
pour peter les aînés ont besoin du
meilleur médicament qui soit l'amour
d'une famille ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal